so just in case and not everyone who's
watching knows exactly what production
design is what is it and how did you get
into it I'm production design but
production designer on the movie is the
person responsible for the overall look
of the film and telling the story
visually I feel strongly that production
design is a narrative tool that there
are ways of of imparting a massive
information that's not written in the
script so that when you you open on the
heroes room you instantly you don't know
how you know that he's you know a nerdy
geek or a lazy good-for-nothing slovenly
old Soto but someone like me has made
those decisions it's also interpreting
sometimes the directors idea of how a
film should look and on other films
directors come to us and say what's my
film gonna look like you've read the
script you've put together some mood
boards you've looked at where they want
to shoot it and you know what the budget
is which is another tool of the design
department and from that give them a
realistic idea of of what what they'll
be seeing in the film and how did you
get into production design and from an
early age I wanted to be the movies I
saw a matter of life and death and and
sort of pointed to the screen I said
that's what I want to do sort of create
that fantasy I had no idea that that the
job existed as most of us didn't and i
did a graphic design degree because it
was the course that taught you the most
stuff when I thought to be in the film
industry you needed to know how to do
things and came out of college thought
I'd go to film school but there wasn't
really a good course royal college of
art course at time was very documentary
and sort of grim gritty realism base and
I wanted to make Hollywood nice
so i bided my time working as
photographer and in the i had a shop in
Kensington Market making clothes for
rock bands and and then I then music
videos happened and I just wangled my
way in with all the skills I'd learn
both you know designing clothes learning
to be designer at college and walk
straight in kind of straight in as a
production designer Erik film that gave
me my first break so did that working on
music videos under that kind of feel
that desire to work on a big Hollywood
musical oh yeah undoubtedly um I mean it
was a great great training ground we
were all learning the directors the
DLP's we'd all come from incredible
varied backgrounds to interpret you know
the music of the late 80s as it was and
we kind of invented how we did it we we
all employed proper technicians and
chippies and sparks mohave and we
learned from them but we also look back
there was no you know post-production
was very very basic in the old days
everything shot and tight film and then
transferred to take to edit so we look
back at old techniques and weary kind of
found silent movie technique split
screen using causes old theatrical
techniques and and put them on to film
and learnt masses and it was very
hands-on time we all did everything you
know I would paint and sore and so and
build and dig holes and waggle hose
pipes around whatever it took which i
think is very important I don't I'm not
asking any of my crew now to do anything
that at some point I haven't done
let's talk a little bit about mutant
chronicles because being here at the sci
fi London Film Festival I guess that's
you talk about green screen earlier
that's were what we're all here for in a
way isn't it and the film set in the
future and in a future is sort of
dystopian steampunk future and very
early on in the process it's a very
ambitious grid and we only had the films
made for nine and a half million pounds
but looks like three times that I worked
incredibly closely with a visit X
department and the right at the
beginning the first thing we did was
break the script down into every scene
and decide we decided that we would
build some element of each set and all
of it once with very that were very
dialogue heavy so making that decision
that say they're crawling through a hole
a sewer hole coming out onto a Ledge
that we would just build the whole about
a metre of rock face and the ledge they
step onto and the rest would be created
in the wild world of digital effects or
miniatures and digital effects we we
gave ourselves miniatures is another
tool so having made that decision the
only thing to do was to stick to it and
throughout the film and by having real
physical elements whether they're
miniatures or actual scenery it gives
weight to the digital images and makes
you believe them so much more it's also
cheaper because you can use elements
that you've built brick rock you know
wood timber rusty metal and grab it and
and replicate it which is much much
deeper than trying to digitally create
everything from scratch we've worked a
lot with Korean screen I think before
had a new but was this your first sign
Pfeiffer was that right yes it was dr.
Jekyll and mr. Hyde
was the previous film that had a lot of
green screen which in its own way as a
sort of Victorian sci-fi movie and we
had dream sequences and john hanna
played both characters and we did some
very interesting having jung as
jekyll-and-hyde on screen together and
it was the same physics company that did
that how difficult is it keeping on top
of all that technology because it as you
say it's changing constantly as a little
it's easy because the technicians
involved in it you know the digital
artist the VIS effects companies
whatever are just delighted to share the
information so basically pick your post
house and then go around for lunch and
they will explain everything and then
when you turn up for a job interview you
are you know you're up with the latest
the latest technology it's another tool
that the green screen the whole that
whole section of pose is an art
department tool it means we can design
bigger and more fantastical amazing
things and shoot them you know
realistically if there was one thing you
had to say to someone who was thinking
of going into production design what
would it be oh and if there's one thing
don't sell yourself short and demand a
proper wage for your for your time and
it is be interested in everything and
every job is different one day it'll be
a sci-fi movie you'll need to be getting
enthusiastic and passionate about
spaceship or some kind of underwater
travel or whatever and next week it
might be a tea party in a garden in
1920s Cambridgeshire if you're
passionate about all those things and
everything then the art department it's
a job for you if you're not don't come
and what are you working on next
Caroline I'm writing a screenplay I've
written a screenplay which is in
development and it's not sci-fi but it's
a a ghost fantasy kids family very
English romp
so what can we look forward to happening
with that next what kind of stage you
and I'm begging for money it's the stage
right at the moment sales agents are
sending me notes just tired of director
who's very enthusiastic I have
introduced obviously so yes it's all new
to me this writing lark but item yeah
and I'm confident that it'll get made
and I won't be production designing it
how does it feel kind of stepping into
that role though moving from production
design moving to the writing side
frustrating because because we're so far
down the light you know way from the
film being made and realizing it and
when I get called for production design
job all that's happened the money's in
place and very often it's you know read
the script what are you doing a Tuesday
can you fly to Romania you know and
that's it for three months you leave
your life behind and and you're straight
in at 100 miles an hour fully immersed
over your head in the project and you
live and breathe it for the time you're
on it and that's exciting and like motor
racing but the sort of plug eNOS of
writing is frustrating I'm looking
forward to the next you know script that
lands on my desk that's ready written
and ready fun bit when we look forward
to seeing your production design on that
script that's going to land on your on
your desk and we look forward to the
development of this script as well good
luck with it thank you very much
you